um
conducting opportunities today right
here we go number one apologies for
absence i think there's a couple
thank you chair apologies from
councillor bushby
oh just one okay sure
can you move them back before
minutes from the last meetings um we
won't call it so i think we just have to
um
by uh rachel
70
anonymous
action list
right hey
what's
regarding the taxi rank
just as yeah this is still with our
property services team at the moment
um we do have to do a demand study this
year so it does sort of link in with
that because if we're going to keep a
restriction on taxis then that's one
issue if we remove the restriction on
taxis well then we're going to have to
look at alternative arrangements because
we would obviously have
potentially a larger number of vehicles
so it's
still in hand with our property services
team to review and we'll bring it back
to a future committee
that's the update yeah this one's
right
declarations of interest
well uh we all know what do we do with
those
so if you have any interests there
declare it uh agreement event there's
only part two items today no part two
items
uh six urgent matters of information
brought forward
right on to seven the small commercial
license vessel licensing policy uh we
needed a report from
preston
yeah this is the our standard
small commercial
small commercial vessel policy
it's last approved by committee back in
2019 so it's due for review
i was hoping to get this done before the
start of the new
season but due to previous meetings
being cancelled i think it's worth now
delaying this until the next
um because the
sort of busy year operates between april
and october
um so the haploid stove ferry's already
started operating um so to bring any
changes in mid-term
is probably not a good idea if we do
bring any changes
but however i would still like to start
the policy review so this is really just
to approve
a six-week consultation on the existing
policy and then we'll bring it back to a
future committee
to
have any issues that are raised and then
we can discuss and finalize the policy
to take into effect um the next next
operating year
[Music]
this is the place or not but um i'm very
concerned that there should be
space for consultation about jet skis
and small powered craft and other
foreign craft
looking through
what other councils are doing there's an
increasing problem
social issue with um power craft up up
and down the country
councils i see in penzance in lancashire
but we're all um
have introduced more stringent measures
to control
craft and particularly jet skis
and i see in other countries we are
sort of simply way behind certain
countries and what we require
i'm just hoping that we can include
uh female consultation such matters as
i need more stringent qualifications and
licenses for owners of power craft
considerations zoning speed limits
insurance age limits
possibly permits and charging at
slipways
and also apart from that
the effect of small power craft
generally on wildlife in the river and
yesterday
um
i'm hoping that those sort of matters
could be included
licensing rather than conduct don't we
and that would be for probably a
different committee wouldn't it
yeah this policy only relates to
vessels for hire
so it's anybody who hires out vessels
for use not general public use so it
wouldn't cover if you bring your own jet
ski down and start
with your own boats or whatever down it
doesn't cover that this covers the
higher specs
at the moment we've only got
two vessels
well we've got the two the epidural and
slow ferry which obviously is operates
in effect the water taxi
and we've got two others who do boat
trips
up the up and down the torridge
so they're being applying for the effect
line for hire being left for hire so
this policy only applies for that if
someone wanted to set up a jet ski hire
business in ecuador car park for
instance
that would come under this policy we
could put any
any condition you know relevant
conditions or restrictions in place that
only applies to higher not individuals
we can't put anything in this policy
that would affect individuals because we
haven't got the
legislation related solely to higher
vessels i got right positive small
commercial vessels and used for sport or
pleasure yes but it's four higher the
definition is or higher so so there's no
opportunity to apply some of the
conditions i've outlined on hiring
companies and
yes on higher companies we can yeah okay
so yeah if if we get a company that
wants to hire jet skis we can then put
conditions on their terms of license oh
that is possible what sort of following
sort of areas i've suggested yes
well that sort of suggests yeah yeah so
we can consider that as part of the
policy review yes do i need to
do a proposal
no this is part of the consultation so
we can you can raise it as part of the
consultation
there's an impact input into the
consultation
we will then bring it back to the future
committee and that can be discussed and
rightly either approved or amended as as
soon as
we see a draft consultation yes we will
send that yes i will send that draft
consultation which will be open yeah for
obviously the committee and everybody
else too and including members of the
public to respond as soon as we've
consultation
yeah are we happy with six weeks or we
want to make we have got to make it
longer if we want to
have a bit longer to
make sure we cover everything
do two licensed operators so
um
so hopefully we can do that six-week
consultation probably not this next week
but a meeting after we might be able to
yes review it again yeah we'll
see what the consultation brings up yeah
so okay
yeah thank you fantastic thank you
anybody else
want to
send for this before we
consider the consultation
so proposing the chair that we put this
out the consultation
i've seconded it
sector
yep
lovely
right uh right now all right mate review
of the taxi policy
okay yes thank you
so as the committee will be aware we
commenced the review of the taxi policy
now back in february 21 and
following various consultations
um we've now got to the stage of having
a final draft policy
members did approve the implementation
of the new safety standards in october
21 so the new policy now incorporates
that
and we also
included some other aspects
highlighted
one
issue that has been raised by the trade
is i just want to clarify if we can
refer to the policy page 24 of the
appendix
so vehicle specification and conditions
of license for taxis
it does apply to the private hires as
well but obviously the same thing
applies
page 65 165 or minus 24 on my one
so
yeah this is the vehicle missions the
authority is seeking to improve air
quality and reduce mission oh as
everybody found it actually yeah yeah
yeah
i just want clarification we've got here
from april 2026 all the vehicles
licensed by tdc will be required
then from april 2013 all vehicles being
licensed for the first time must have
co2 emissions less than 50.
so
the wording that that states that by
2026 all vehicles must be euro six
whereas by april 2013 it's only first
time it renews it would need to be
um less than 20
less than 50
um or electric
so i just want to
that means that as of first of april
2026 any existing vehicles would cease
to be
suitable for licensing i just want to
clarify that or are we going to give a
lead for existing drivers are we going
to give a lead-in period for instance
another 12 months or whatever to release
they've still got a non-euro 6x8 for
2026. are we going to give them a
leading period or do we think what we
now 2022 a four-year leading period is
sufficient to give
the the trade time to if they haven't
got euros it's vehicle to upgrade
just from that clarify
well bearing in mind
we're committed to zero carbon by
but most modern taxi
people
would have changed their vehicle in the
next four years i would have thought to
a more modern vehicle going forward
you know because of
just the cost of running a diesel
vehicle at the moment is getting must be
getting beyond the job
you know i mean we all know in our own
pockets with diesel it's horrendous so
you know
you know so i appreciate they've got a
problem but four years from now we'd
hope that
things would approve so
you know i can't give you a
ballpark figure there are vehicles that
change quite frequently and others
not the top of my head no i don't
unfortunately no i was just thinking
that you know
if nobody is meeting that requirement
now
that's four years isn't enough time to
follow
the taxi drivers
are feeling the pinch exactly the same
as
everyone else
i'm just a bit conscious of the fact
that it won't get any better and
perhaps we do need a roof a couple more
years for a lead-in
for the children chance to
um
you know get their money together
and get their finances together to buy
new vehicles i mean other goals that we
we have a lead in six years not just for
charging these vehicles and you know
everybody's feeling a pitch i mean it's
not something that on you know
on the horizon
so i would agree with uh cancer
or second
okay so we've got a proposal a second
essay
i suppose you have to have a vote on
this stuff whether we have a six-year
lead in or or leave us
um
in the policy of four years in 2026 so
all those in favor of a six year leading
please show
[Music]
two
goes against
four
i'll sting
so that motion is defeated i'm afraid
it's going to be a four-year leader
okay so that's as was done okay so we'll
keep that as this that's my only
issue i wanted to raise is there's any
other
items that
or if not we can approve the policy
for a first of june
start
well i proposed it from the chair that
we
accept this as chris says for the 1st of
june
accept the policy as is
with second then 10 seconds
[Music]
in respect of the infrastructure
situation obviously
we've got scope to review this policy as
time goes on if it's
obvious that the infrastructure isn't
going to be in place by 2030 and it's
going to be impossible
to operate electric vehicles and
obviously we will have to review the
policy um
but i think if we
we got to be setting goals and this is
our goal set in
um
hopefully it's achievable if not we can
always bring it back to this committee
review extension as
some circumstances dictate
if we find out how many people are
complaining already yeah i can find that
out and we can see we'll bring that to
the
committee and see the potential impact
yes
so
just generally just look at the figures
for electric car purchase and i mean
they're taking off and also
there's an item yesterday about second
hand electric vehicle purchase which is
increased dramatically so
you know one would hope that
infrastructure is also going to increase
significantly in the next four years
i realize that electric vehicles are you
know the capital cost is expensive at
the moment but hopefully that will come
down as well
okay so that's um past them did you know
something else about
training
oh yeah i've had some some queries
related to the training aspects that are
required for new drivers um there is a
loan there isn't some national shortage
of drivers at the moment
at the moment we require new drivers to
undertake a btec qualification
um obviously with the age of
online trading and things coming in it
might be that we could review that and
maybe do something a bit
less cumbersome on the trade um but i
need to have a research with that and
consult with other authorities so we're
in line with them and see what they're
doing so that's an item i'll bring back
to a future committee
is the the training requirements for the
triumphs
every little helps that'll be good
okay moving on uh
number nine review of taxi fares
okay so
yes the local authorities have power to
set affairs for happening carriages
under section 65 of the government
miscellaneous provisions act
the last fair increase was on the 1st of
october 2020. as we're all aware there's
been a significant rise in fuel in
living costs over the last few months
and
therefore the council has received a
request from the trade to review
the taxi fares
consultation was undertaken in april
um in the report sets out the results of
that consultation um
as you're aware we've got restricted
plates so there are in total 26 licensed
happy carriage proprietors
14 of those responded of those 14 that
responded
nine were in favor of an increase and
five were against
so
marginally in those that did
reply are in favor of an increase
but there was only a 54
response rate
i met with the tax relations committee
um
most of those that are here today
and we discussed the various options um
the trade out put through a number of
options so we tried to try to whittle
that down to
free options um which are in table one
there is an error
actually in option c
which says a flag fair of four pounds
and
a 280 thereafter that should be 260
thereafter
um because as it reads at the moment b
and c are exactly the same
so
option a is to increase the flag fair to
four pounds and a three pound per mile
thereafter which gives a
two mile rate of 775
b option b is a four pound flag fair 280
thereafter which would be a 750
mile rate
and then c is four pounds but 260
per mile thereafter
which would be 725 it's worth pointing
out that 260 per mile
is the existing rate the existing rate
is 317 per three-quarters
and 260 thereafter so in effect
option c would only give them a 30 pence
per fair
increase
because the further you
keep in the thereafter miles the same
means no matter however you go to
um
northern or or basketball you still only
get a
fake seven increases that makes sense
the 30 pence increase
um
moving on to the national context
um
the
private higher end taxi monthly magazine
produces a monthly
um
rate list where they show that the
average two mile fare for all
authorities
in
in england which is 349 actually set
rates or that includes unitaries and
things so yeah 349.
on our current existing rate we were
44th
um
so i also put in a comparison with other
devon authorities in table two
in the left-hand column estimated
position
there are as you can imagine a number of
authorities are now updating their fare
so this is almost like an ongoing change
at the moment
but as it stood on the 3rd of may
torridge was
57th um so we were the highest
in devon
having said that as you can see in the
far column
north devon council are proposing the
730 increase torque bay have proposed a
743 increased east coast proposal 715
increase
south hams have already completed their
2022 review in
666 and likewise plymouth have completed
theirs for 60 so there is
um
comparison there with with other
other demon authorities
so it's really for the committee to
decide
is a fair increase appropriate and if so
what would be an appropriate rate
[Music]
well how do we feel members do we think
that
with the cost of diesel and everything
else they do need a fair increase
but um i mean we've got this committee
here what do they think i mean you know
are they allowed to speak or
[Music]
there was a mixed response when we had
the committee um
there was
five members at the committee and three
were favored two were against
so it's
fairly close
there is it's marginally in favor of an
increase
but it is very close
well we are we we've got to decide
whether it's going to be increased
increase a b or c yes yeah or you can
set your road down
to fourth option there is a full option
of doing your own break this is the
rates that were discussed
and the um
and the proposals that we decided to put
forward
well yeah
yeah yeah
the trades
yeah
if you're good
right morning ladies and gentlemen first
of all thank you for your time and
consideration of this
as the councillor was saying chris has
been good enough to come up with a cost
of living which is the middle option
that's i think it was about 7.5 percent
give or take yeah the option b i didn't
actually state to the to the committee
that option b was
based on the consumer price index which
is a monthly
um rate of how it's increased which is
the cost of living increase basically
how much of a basket of
so many items have gone up and i took
the rate from october 2020 which is when
we have the last increase up to
march which was the
earliest or the latest available figures
when i did the report so that came out
to 7.2
so basically the middle line the b
option 750 is a 7.2 percent increase in
line with the consumer pricing bits and
the the a option is is that you know
above 10 but as you all know i think the
fuels gone up by about 30 35 percentage
two years ago so uh yeah we'd appreciate
the very least we're hoping for to be
fair is the figures that uh chris came
up with ideally to tie this over
and bearing in mind we've got the new
vehicle um bit on the horizon as well is
option eight but i'll leave that to your
uh your time okay thank you thank you
does anybody else want to speak from
there
i do really sympathize with the taxi
drivers that you know the cost of uh
fuel etc but you also have to balance it
against the fact that more people are
going to be struggling and
a lot of people rely on taxes especially
now the buses
so i don't know whether we need to
strike a balance or not really it's just
a difficult one i mean perhaps the taxi
drivers can say
you know what effect they think that
the a
number eight the first increase 775
would have
on their trade would it actually
dissuade people from using taxes or not
they think that
you know people are still gonna
use the taxes at that increased charge
okay but you know i think we should bear
in mind the effect on the public really
the taxi fare is the maximum that can be
charged
so if the rate say yeah you get the taxi
and you get your two mile rate and it's
775 there's nothing to stop
them being charged seven pounds or six
pounds you can charge under the rate
you can't charge over the rate so the
maximum is the maximum but there's
nothing to stop you charging under the
rate yeah so
there is a
so there is a competition element
between the drivers themselves they can
reduce the rate so if we give them the
maximum
rate
then
that that gives them leeway then up to
that point they can't go over that point
but they can go up to that point and
that seems quite fair
the amount of customers that we use it
how you know they'll say actually that's
too much for me so you reduce the amount
of customers go to it but also we are
asking them to replace that vehicle in
four years time you don't need money to
do that with yeah
if their business drops off and they
want to charge less
to to bring in more business and
advertise or with we charge less i mean
we might end up with a bidding war right
now
but i mean that gives them the option
we're just setting the maximum saying
you can't charge any more than this
you know and i think personally i think
if you give them the highest option
you know and leave them themselves to
decide
you know i mean they're all individual
people leave them
the chance to decide what they can
afford to charge
you know i mean if you've just bought a
2020
car
you know and you've got higher
repayments you've got to decide
you know how much i can afford to charge
my customers
a to live
and b to pay the repayments on the car
you know if you're driving around in a
10 year old car
you've got equal the same problems do i
keep this clapped out thing on the road
you know and keep pouring money into it
or do i invest in my future
what you're asking them to do is
uh for 2026 we're asking them to invest
in their future it's their business i've
been a business person for
i don't know 30 years and i've always
had to put my hand in my pocket to
invest in my business
you know and that's that's but that's
their job if they don't want to invest
in their business then like a lot of
businesses some businesses will fall
some businesses won't that's
life
i think if we give them the chance to
have the maximum a
then they can decide up to a
you know if you give them a lesser
chance
then then that restricts their chance of
earning
so and personally this is a personal
from a business point of view i would
give them option a the maximum we we're
allowed to give them at this moment in
time
and then they'll decide
they'll make the decision how you know
what their business can afford to take
or not take
first proposals
yeah they can so i'll propose a and b
[Music]
um i think that's the most sensible
investment thing to do to for them and
the future christmas questions when
would be the next review affair
no
the price is going to go up at least
number five or six thousand pounds on
each vehicle
and the price rise at the moment when
you come close
it might come down though i doubt it
the cost of cars at the moment has been
second hand
and i would pay for it
because people cannot get the cars
and the price is going to get going up
and up and up you're very christian you
have to go astronomical in the end to
keep up with it i think that we'll have
to keep an eye on that on the prices
let's see how it's going
okay 12 month review uh cancer rich
thank you chair
i've got i've got a lot of sympathy for
the taxis and
charges and i i hear what country
crosstalk and
extra hands
but we if you look at the figures
torridge is still the highest charging
authority
if you look at those figures i mean
you look at safe hands for instance in
66
they've got the same pressure as they're
in straight fast with phil the same as
we have
now
you know
like i said simply i'm i'm torn like
potentially slightly like this
because if we're gonna put it up
hiking up to the top
that's been is up the 16th
range
you know
torridge is the most deprived area
in devon
and yet our taxi fare is going to be the
highest in them
now it doesn't
sit right with me somewhere
and i'm just wondering how the taxi
drivers and safe hounds
can make a living on 666
and we can't know what orange is still
higher at the moment
on the
695. i mean it's just
i was
the question is
plymouth and so found
the most affluent
uh districts
in devon
and yet they have the lowest
uh affairs in general
i would think that that might be to do
with population density
[Music]
is also met with how many taxis they
have so they've got more taxis on the
road so yeah i couldn't see a better
plan for that i don't see that argument
really because they probably i don't
know top plymouth but i think three
times as many taxis there's torrents yes
gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
they've gone up to 730 aren't they
you know
[Music]
75 yeah but we're only we're only
putting out the maximum i don't know i
don't know what you're saying i mean
there's a trade can discount or offer
or have a lower rate
i hear what mr uh
i understand that
but we're still hiking it up to the
maximum more than anybody else
that's uh i know councilman says it's
it's it's a maximum it's like a speed
limit in it you've started our speed you
don't have to do that it's not a target
i i ring up taxi drivers and say if six
of us were going out somewhere
uh in a long journey i said how much do
you do it for can they give me a price
yeah unless they're protected
they can still do that i understand that
all i'm saying is that we're hiking it
up
to the biggest charge
they can make in denim
it gives them the maximum amount of
flexibility and they don't have to
charge that amount
exactly i don't understand that okay
well
right
the arguments i think so um
do are we in mind to have an increase
there's the first
thing
yes
right so we're gonna have an increase so
now i suppose the options are a b or c
or option d if anybody's got any
option a so that was proposed by
councillor
yeah we have got one container
that's proposed and seconded for option
a is there any other proposals
well
i propose that we call for being
actually that's the cost of living right
i think that's fair
i would second next so we've got 202 on
the table
so if
anybody else
nope so i'll take them in the order that
they were proposed then so
uh the first one would be
councillor kant's proposal i think that
yeah of option a um
against
three
well staying
so that motion's carried um
option a is the
new rate
it would be the new rate
flag for the
increased at four quid uh three quarter
mile after that so two mile rate 775.
[Music]
that's carried
do we have anything else for this
no just uh that was just to clarify
point three we now need to advertise
those rates
for 14 days
which can be subject to public um
objection if we have a public objection
we then have to
re-review
we provide those objections we propose a
first june increase
sure did you
yeah could you answer the question about
how long the
increase last
but we review but we're going to review
it in 12 months just to see if it's
working or not and
we do fair reviews as when required
really
let's put that either
[Music]
so we do need
to
one thing we are proposing is to
introduce an animal licensing policy we
haven't got animal welfare licensing
policy at the moment
um so we're proposing to introduce one
of them so i'll bring that to a future
committee
um
okay other than that is nothing specific
at the moment there is a review of the
boat policy which we need to come back
to committee
yeah i'm going um
put in the taxi
after that
if we do
the animal policy center september
possibly
and then we'll see what comes up in the
interim there are more changes of foot
with taxis
they're reviewing the um
the best practice guide the department
for transport have a best practice guide
for tax scenes and that was last week
2010s now going out for consultation
to review that so there may be some
issues
that we need to come back into this
committee it depends what the
final
final report comes out as but that may
be if several months before the actual
final documents approved
anybody's got anything to go on the
forward plan
okay um
right there is no
part two um so that's the end of the
meeting thank you very much